[Music]
hey what's up guys mkbhd here so
typically with every single new version
of android we'll get an early look at it
in the form of an alpha or beta release
then we'll dig into it find the coolest
new features and then share it with you
guys now this year with android 11 those
earlier builds were
honestly a little bit underwhelming like
the alpha builds were not super feature
rich and they weren't ready but now that
we're getting towards that time of year
where we were supposed to have google i
o which was of course canceled but now
that we're getting to that time
the beta builds that are coming out
especially this first one
are a lot more close to final and
there's some good stuff in here so we're
going to dive in and take a look now
keep in mind
android as just as a whole
is a lot more well baked more mature
than it was a couple years ago so a
couple years ago a version update like
this could be a whole visual overhaul
this isn't a visual overhaul anymore
this is a lot more tweaking a lot more
fine tuning but there is still some cool
stuff and some good features in here so
that's what we're gonna take a look at
and uh yeah so this is the top five new
features in android 11. and number five
is the updated pixel launcher so this
has been my favorite launcher i guess on
any android phone for a couple years now
anytime i get a new phone i just kind of
try to make the home screen feel kind of
like a pixel but they have tweaked some
stuff here so first of all they let me
turn auto rotation on on the home screen
which correct me if i'm wrong that
wasn't enabled before so you can just
turn your phone sideways like a tablet
and just use it like that right away i
don't think i ever would use my phone
like this on the home screen i almost
never turn it that way anyway so
it's cool i don't think that was enabled
before then there's now a new option for
your bottom row of apps to be app
suggestions so basically it moves
everything up a row and then that whole
new bottom row is suggested apps to open
on your phone based on learned behaviors
and you can pin a suggested app in place
down there if you think it should be
there permanently and there's also an
option in settings to block an app from
ever showing up there so just check the
box if you don't want it to ever be
suggested this to me is
of neat i guess if those suggestions get
really good but i'm not a huge fan of
the idea of my home screen being
variable i i feel like they should just
stay locked in place so i have quick
access to everything now inside the app
drawer they let you have that top row as
suggestions that's cool i'll leave it
like that it's been like that for years
but yeah i think i'm probably not gonna
use that option then the app switcher is
also a little bit different huge cards
still but now you get an app screenshot
button a share button and a select
button to select text within the app and
you now lose the extra pull down up to
get into the app drawer and there's some
small new animations did you catch that
you can see the wallpaper shifts a bit
when you pull the notification bar down
and it also shifts when you pull up into
the app drawer it's it's really subtle
it's super subtle but that's nice all
right so number four is the new media
controls up at the top now this is an
option that's actually not enabled by
default and i suspect that's because
it's a bit buggy and incomplete but when
you do go into the developer settings
and enable it it puts this little
colorized media widget in the top of
your quick settings pull down i think
this is sweet it's like an androidized
version of the iphone's quick settings
media toggle
and since it's at the top it means you
never have to scroll very far to pause
whatever music or podcast you're
listening to now like i said it is a bit
buggy but you can have more than one
open at once
but it doesn't yet work with every
single app like it doesn't work with
youtube yet and also sometimes the
playback scrubber doesn't work but
generally i'm a big fan of this feature
you can also quickly toggle playback
devices so if you have headphones or
speakers paired stuff like that you can
quickly get to that
and the little mini player the color of
it is always going to match the album
art of whatever you're listening to so
again very subtle but that's nice all
right number three
three
voice access or voice control full
credits to dieter from the verge for
surfacing this for me i saw it on his
twitter he tweeted a video of using it
and it blew my mind i'll link his tweet
below but basically it's an
accessibility feature so not everyone's
gonna use it but i feel like anything
that improves accessibility on a phone
this much could be used by anyone
basically and and when it gets this good
it's worth it so here's how it works so
the voice access feature itself is not
new you can grab it from the play store
it shows up in the menus of your phone
and when you enable it in this new
android beta
it's controlling the phone with your
voice and the best improvement here is
instead of just saying the number
corresponding to what you want to press
you can actually also just say the name
of the action and it's gotten really
good at responding open relay pro
scroll down
scroll up
go home
open chrome
scroll up
go back
open twitter
tweet
this is a test
of
voice commands on android 11.
delete all text
go back
go home
that's pretty good okay so number two
the power button hold which is usually
just to like turn off the phone or reset
gets even more functionality now i'm not
sure why
they chose the power button hold for
this stuff other than just giving quick
access to things that weren't originally
quick but here we are so now when you
press and hold the power button instead
of just getting shutdown restart and
screenshot you get all those things plus
a shortcut to google pay and whatever
other cards and passes like boarding
passes you have which is broken right
now in this beta and then also a bunch
of smart home toggles and i happen to
have some compatible smart home stuff
that i can control so i can turn on my
smart lights on and off and they work
pretty quickly it seems like and nest
thermostat also works quickly and easily
and you can even preview nest cameras
now again i don't know if putting them
here in the power button long press menu
is what i expected or what most users
will expect to find here but i'm cool
with it side note if you aren't you can
go into the system settings under power
menu and take away the things that you
don't care about having here and then
number one the biggest new change in yet
another android update is a new
notification shade
classic android update so in android 11
the notifications get separated into
three categories there's conversations
alerting notifications
and silent notifications so
conversations is for messaging basically
so text messages twitter dms or whatever
other apps end up supporting this i
imagine slack and other messaging apps
then alerting notifications is basically
all the standard stuff that's where
you'd have them pile up normally and
then silent notifications are the ones
that are persistent happening in the
background more background stuff like
weather or google now cards it's also
got these more jelly animations they're
pretty sloppy actually at the moment in
this beta but i think they can clean
them up and they'll look nice
and that's the real
main change here there's also some other
little things like you can do bubble
notifications now so basically chat
heads are being supported for messaging
apps this is a thing you can turn on and
off in the settings i was never really a
huge fan of chat heads so i'm keeping it
off
and then there's also a new fancy screen
on and off animation see it's there's a
lot of little things definitely little
things
and that is it for android 11. my
favorite new feature of these is
definitely the the new media controls up
in the top nice little compact widget up
here because i'm always
listening i feel like to something music
or a podcast but i'm curious let me know
in the comment section what your
favorite feature of these five is now at
the end of the day the unanswered
question is when will you get this
update like when will you try this new
stuff because i'm testing it right now
on my pixel 4. and that's what you'd
expect is a pixel to get it and there's
a couple other pixel models that can
download it and test it right now some
people are literally dailying this beta
but there's kind of no way to know when
a samsung phone uh htc phone a motorola
phone and oneplus phone are all going to
get it when the carriers will allow it
so i
i don't know if you want to guarantee
that you get these latest features
in your phone you have to have a pixel
basically and that's the way it's been
for a little while but
other than that that's about all we know
that's the top five features in android
11. if you have any questions feel free
to drop them below and we can chat about
them but
that's been it thanks for watching
catch you guys the next one
peace